bonne journée pour les médecins, l'amour n'est pas
qui n'est pas allé chercher a aussi écrit un
public ou plus tard avez-vous pensé qu'il
s'il n'y a pas de pa n'est pas encore
diminue diminue Il en va de même pour les politiciens et
[Musique]
aller
être difficile à chercher Candida
Candida un
et celui-ci ils font remonter que celui qui
le choso il y a on veut savoir où
ont eu la vision les autres avec du pain qui
il vient ici avec moi chaque fois qu'il a
un partenaire vous qui n'a conduit à aucun IPC
est libre noir et qui ne se refroidit pas
ceux qui ont gagné une reconstruction je
sont déjà doit être si froid que le
les gens n'étaient pas ceux qu'il avait jusqu'à
où laser Jet nous même
déjà
bon ok il y a une chaîne et
non
est journaliste et
dans l'interview questions-réponses
et le navire n'en connaissait pas un que je l'ai pris
pour gagner commencer à dormir et sortir de
Ferro ex-plus, c'est ça, c'est différent
explosif
sans abandonner réponds moi là pour te voir
qui m'a dit qu'on s'occupe du groupe et
n'est pas
et le lien ce spectacle de conception comme celui-ci
non elle suivra sans
le problème est que vous avez ici en fait
alors ce sera bleu
Un dernier